have you ever been a victim of online
abuse and you think this issue is
becoming more common well our next guest
has received abuse for simply posting
gym workout pictures on her social media
account now you'll recognize her she is
sky sports presenter Anna wall house
morning to you Anna and now obviously I
follow you on social media and I'm used
to seeing you in the gym when you're not
on the telly I mean you work out and you
look very good for it and but recently
there's been a bit of a backlash to
pictures you've posted talk to me about
what's been happening to you yeah I mean
I am in the gym a lot and I do post a
lot on social media because I am all for
promoting a healthy lifestyle you know I
actively lift weights and I'm all for
encouraging more women to do so and you
know I get the job I do I know I'm on TV
and it kind of opens yourself up to a
lot only a lot of criticism and you get
the odd comment about the way you look
and you can kind of take that on the
chin a little bit but over the weekend I
received a level of abuse that is just
unacceptable really you know wishing me
dead bringing up horrible things about
my family you know bringing up a subject
that's very very painful to me about my
brother and his death and just body
shaming me in the most horrific way
because you lift weights and some of the
comments you were getting were your two
muscly you don't look very feminine and
another sports presenter Kirsty Yeller
and post a lot of gym pictures as well
and she's come in for this kind of abuse
it's talking about women and what it is
to be feminine and that must be really
upsetting because you look fantastic and
what it helped me body exactly what is
feminine you know what what one person
might deem attractive or feminine or the
perfect ideal and how a woman should
look it is not necessarily what another
person thinks I trained for me and for
me alone and I also trained for a lot of
health reasons like I said and for my
body and my mind you know that's
massively important to me but I
certainly don't train to look like a
certain way it's just a result of the
training but you know what what is it
what is right for some guy to say or
some someone
to say just matter who it is that you're
to muscly or you're too fat or you're
too thin it's interesting isn't it
because when you get negative comments
on social media you're told to ignore it
there's a mute button there is a block
button but it reached peak for you over
the weekend
what can you do about it I mean
obviously you reply to some of these
trolls and you retweeted some of their
comments to say I'm not looking for
sympathy but I just want to highlight
what is going on here something needs to
be done and that is the problem even
though you can mute or block them
there's no punishment for these people
absolutely nothing they can hide behind
your keyboard there is no profile
picture you can't trace these people and
yet you know they think it's alright to
say these horrific things your face if
someone came to you in the street and
said I wish you dead or some said some
horrible things about you they know the
police would probably be involved
because it wouldn't be allowed so what
makes okay to be allowed on social media
and you know yes we do get comments in
the public eye you are kind of I guess
some people might say fair game but to
what extend you you can brush off
certain comments but I'm only human do
you think social media companies need to
do more they will argue there is a blog
button or a mute button but you know the
nature of it is people will set up other
accounts and then carry on tweeting you
absolutely that definitely needs some
more to be done absolutely I mean
whether the a lot of people have come
out of this I mean there has been the
the positive that's come out of this
I've had some amazing support and some
amazing comments since what's happened
but you know the common consensus seems
to be that people said what about being
very won't be verified and it would that
be a solution so you can trace where
these people come from and make them
responsible users and the question is
not everybody is as robust and
thick-skinned as you because like you
said you take it as part of the job but
of course there are certain things that
are going to get to you but if that
abuse is targeted at a young boy or girl
the effects can be devastating
absolutely and and since this has
happened I think we know when you get
the odd nasty message or when I've had
the nasty message in the past you do
brush it off I'm not going to lie it
does get you I am human and sir
on the weekend it was really bad but
this is highlighted to me of going you
know I am lucky that I I did post out
the thing in us enough and I'm going to
put it out there and I got an amazing
response some people don't have you know
friends family or have a platform
thought to be able to do that and and
really sadly it sometimes ends in really
grave circumstances does it make you
want to come off social media I thought
about it yeah and you've decided to stay
on it cuz the nature of it is for your
work for your work it is part and parcel
of being on it but do you think you will
now change the way you post pictures no
I'm not gonna change the way I post
pictures because I like I said I'd do it
for me and also if me posting a workout
video makes one person get off the sofa
and go to the gym or lead a healthy
lifestyle if I can be slightly
motivational for them then that's really
I'm kind of doing what I set out to do
and also my social media is kind of for
me I I enjoy doing it so I did think
about it but no I'm not going to come
off and I'm not going to change well I'm
glad you didn't let them win and thank
you so much for coming in and sharing
your experiences I'm sure it will
resonate with many people at home and
what's your Twitter handle for people
who want to get in touch with you in a
positive way I have got a lot of yes the
response and that has been the good
thing that's come out of it at Wooley
Anna there you go and she is staying on
social media thank you very much Anna
lovely to see you as always